THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTY FIRST IN THE SUMMER
SOLSTICE.
IS HEREBY COLD ORDER --
PLEASE BE ADVISED OF THE AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDING IS BEING MADE THIS
ALSO TELEVISED.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
CERVANTES HERE FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON HERE MAYES HERE THIS
AREA.
SALAS PRESENT WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA.
SO MOST OF THE CONSENT AGENDA
[inaudible]
SEC OURSELVES SALAS SECOND
PREMISE.
CERVANTES --
MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE MATES AYE MAYES AYE IN THIS
AREA.
SALAS AYE SALAS AYE WALDRON.
MOTIONS PAST --
SO THE RULES COULD IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU